vielen dank michael sah ja wir sind auf
der schlussgerade von zwei
sitzungswochen in folge nächste woche
dann mal keine ausschüsse kein plenum
aber in der woche danach ist dann die
sogenannte haushaltswoche da geht es um
viele zahlen um viel geld und um viele
etats erweitern werden politische
vorhaben also in geld quasi umgesetzt
und dann wird es unter anderem auch
wahrscheinlich um das sogenannte
sondervermögen gehen für die bundeswehr
die bekannten 100 milliarden da wirken
wie heute tagesordnungspunkte zum thema
bundeswehr fast schon ein klein wenig
wie alltag sind sie aber nicht denn es
geht ja eh schon michael sei eben gesagt
hat unter anderem um die
bundeswehreinsätze in mali aber auch
ideen in libanon und da gibt es eine
ganze menge zusammenhänge wenn man das
ganze mal bei licht betrachtet um
darüber wollen wir jetzt schon mal reden
und zwar mit simplen möller der
parlamentarischen staatssekretärin bei
der bundesverteidigungsminister rinn und
sie kommt aus der spd-fraktion guten
morgen hin und ali al dailami es bei uns
der stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion zugleich deren
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher auch
ihnen schönen guten morgen frau
müller die vor ein paar wochen haben wir
noch den diskussionen darüber gehabt die
das die bundeswehreinsätze in mali
möglicherweise ganz aufgehoben werden
jetzt ist es so dass die eu mission an
der die bundeswehr beteiligt ist sich
aus mali quasi zurückzieht sie wird
halbiert man wechselt in den niger als
haupt stationierung punkt und die un
mission an der die bundeswehr beteiligt
wenn die bundeswehr anzahl der
bundeswehr soldaten sogar erhöht also
ein ganz anderer verlauf als die
diskussionen sich anfang des jahres zu
entwickeln erschien warum das ganze
wir haben wir heute hier maria im
prinzip ein mandat was 3 soll ich ist ja
einmal den ausbildungsteil werden den
beratungs teil für mali und wir haben
dann die ausbildung der spezialkräfte in
emea hat das finden wir auch schon eine
ganze weile durch und es seit einigen
jahren der mandatierung es wichtig beim
user ein so verlässlicher partner ist
und wir dort sehen dass das was dort
durchgeführt wird tatsächlich einen
effekt hat und auch hochwillkommen es
wollen wir den fall unbedingt fortführen
und wir wollen die ausbildung der
malischen streitkräfte aussetzen und
erst wenn die gegebenheiten sich
verändert haben dann muss der bundestag
tag entscheiden ob wir die ausbildung da
wieder aufnehmen dürfte aber so weit ist
dieser zeit auf jeden fall beendet und
bei - man muss man sagen als dass man
sagen dass die un mission ist soll die
abkürzungen wie allen ganz so präsent
wie bei ihnen hier weil - man ist es ja
so dass wir dort insbesondere da sind um
die zivilbevölkerung zu schützen im
auftrag der vereinten nationen auch um
beispielsweise die lieferung des world
food programms abzusichern oder um die
verteilzentren abzusichern so dass dazu
mindestens noch ein gewisses maß an
schutz und auch an entwicklungshilfe
zustande kommt wenn ich das bild bemühen
darf - meist das einzige was den
intensivpatienten war die dann noch am
leben hält beziehungsweise anschluss
bieten krank für die zivilbevölkerung ja
al dailami wir kennen die position der
linken zu auslandseinsätzen der
bundeswehr auch zur bundeswehr im
allgemeinen und besonderen aber frau
müller hat ja eben noch mal gesagt es
geht um den schutz der zivilbevölkerung
in mali unter antwort unter anderem das
was spricht dagegen diese mission
fortzusetzen aus ihrer sicht wir reden
jetzt über die un-mission man muss erst
mal feststellen also wo frau müller
absolut recht hat ist natürlich das teil
der mission auch die absicherung von
hilfslieferungen ähnliches ist in diesem
punkt hat sie das richtig dargestellt
unser problem ist bei diesem einsatz man
muss konstatieren dass er eigentlich
gescheitert ist wenn man die anderen
zielpunkte sich vergegenwärtigt also man
redet davon auch im antragstext unter
punkt 3 heute dass man die staatliche
autorität in mali wiederherstellen will
aber auch dem friedensschluss zwischen
der damaligen malischen regierung und
rebellengruppen von algier 2015 umsetzen
wir das problem ist wir haben seit dem 2
regierungen in mali gehabt da frage ich
mich was will man da wieder herstellen
als staatlicher autorität und die
unterzeichner des friedensabkommens von
algier die sind nebst der malischen
regierung die vector putsch wurde auch
nicht mehr da die zweite zweite
unterzeichner wurde ermordet die dritte
gruppe ist mittlerweile aktiv mit der al
qaida und beteiligt sich an drogen und
menschenhandel und das ist höchst
problematisch zumal das auch der
verlustreichste 1 der verlustreichsten
einsätze seit nur ein einsatz damals im
koreakrieg es mit über 270 toten und
wenn ich das im verhältnis setze dann
glaube ich und kommen wir auch zu dem
schluss dass das völlig
unverhältnismäßig ist mir das leben
unserer soldaten unserer worten dort
enorm riskieren weil die ganze sahelzone
desolat ist mittlerweile und wie ein
klick schon nach dem anderen erleben und
das ist ein großes problem zentraler
punkt der anspricht liebe auch wenn man
sich in der vorbereitung damit
beschäftigt irgendwie das natürlich die
frage ist wer ist eigentlich der an
recht partner in mali klar es gibt im
moment im militär eine
übergangsregierung aber was sie will ist
relativ uneindeutig sie haben sich jetzt
mit dem franzosen angelegt deshalb die
franzosen sich im sommer und zumindest
aus dem teil der mission auch
zurückziehen werden hat man überhaupt
noch gibt es noch die legitimation die
diese missionen am anfang hatten ist das
ist ja genau der punkt der auch hier
angesprochen durch den weg den sie jetzt
auch unterstreichen dass wir deswegen
die ausbildung der malischen
streitkräfte aussetzen weil der
europäischen trainingsmission wir
beraten heute oder beschließen noch zwei
missionen einmal die trainingsmission
die im prinzip kasse die billigen
filmische streitkräften fasste das wird
ausgesetzt und gleichzeitig haben wir
eine mission der vereinten nationen die
eben nicht die
kapazitive linken passt sondern schutz
der zivilbevölkerung nicht ich teile das
dass die sahelzone wirklich auch in
einem kritischen punkt ist und für mich
ist das genau das argument dann dort zu
bleiben weil wir etwas passiert wenn man
wenn man wenn wir dort jetzt auch noch
abziehen auch - mag das haben wir an
vielen orten der welt gesehen dass
daneben die stabilität und sicherheit
komplett zusammen richtung deswegen
beteiligt ist dass im moment der
richtige dass die situation kritisch ist
und man trotzdem dort bleiben muss ein
weiterer punkt der angesprochen wurde
zum schutz der soldaten soldaten ist es
deswegen im mandatstext explizit auch
aufgenommen worden mit der luft nach
unterstützung weil wir weil wir auch aus
sicht des bmvg ist natürlich sehr klar
wissen dass die luftunterstützung durch
die französische kampfhubschrauber nicht
mehr so gegeben sein wird aufgrund des
abzuges in die französischen der anteile
vollziehen werden und dementsprechend
muss dafür gesorgt werden dass die luft
nach unterstützung beziehungsweise
schutz komponente gegeben ist dafür
haben wir ein bisschen zeit aber eben
auch noch eine ganze menge hausaufgaben
zu machen ist denn da ansatzweise klar
wie diese lücke ich sag jetzt mal
gestopft werden sollen wurden
bundesverteidigungsministerium hat
appelliert dass die vereinten nationen
dar aktiver sein müssen
bundesverteidigungsminister man hat sehr
deutlich gemacht dass tief dass die
vereinten nation aktiver sein müssen und
wir wir müssen
das haben wir deswegen auch so im
mandatstext aufgenommen das ist aufgabe
auch der organisation ist wohl wissend
dass die organisation natürlich auch
noch den mitgliedstaaten besteht wir
haben keine eigene fähigkeit die wir
einbringen könnten dementsprechend
müssen andere mitgliedstaaten kopf diese
fähigkeit der franzosen substituieren
wir wissen dass es viele gespräche gibt
mit den niederländern insbesondere und
das ist dann eben etwas was die
internationale gemeinschaft gemeinsam
stellen muss wenn mal ihr so wichtig ist
was ja durch die vereinten nationen und
die mitgliedstaaten dann auch so geteilt
wird gibt es her als alternative zu dem
was vor müller sagt und was auch diese
un-mission angeht wenn man den blick
richten will auf eine relativ stabile
lage im land wenn man einen blick
richten will auf den schutz der
zivilbevölkerung sehen sie alternativen
also das problem ist ja erst mal dass
man immer glaubt man müsse mit
militärischen mitteln aktiv sein um wie
hier behauptet wird und auch um
hilfsgüter und ähnliches abzusichern bis
zum gewissen grad kann das auch
funktionieren das problem ist aber dass
wir erleben dass das gezeigt hat ist
diese militärischen interventionen und
militärische beihilfe ist gescheitert
weil wir wie gesagt eins nach dem
anderen haben und spielen noch eines zu
bedenken geben haben sie eben schon
erläuterte sogar mehr punkte haben auch
verstanden das sehen auch die
alternative ist diese äußere einmischung
die einhergeht ist eine einmischung die
stadt findet ich bin nur daran erinnern
diese einsätze sind alle in folge
französischer vormals gelaufene einsätze
die beendet worden sind stichwort
ehrwald die mission und frankreich hat
dort einfach ökonomische interessen die
sich aus ihrer sicht legitim meinen zur
verfolgung zu wollen und das hat die
lage dem er die stabilisiert und ist
glaube und bin fest davon überzeugt dass
die menschen dort und die regierung dort
wenn man sie alleine ihre probleme und
ihre kulturellen eigenheiten und die
lösungs prozesse die sie selbst
entwickeln können wenn man sie wirklich
lässt dass sie dann es überhaupt eine
chance bekommen zu frieden schließen
bekomme ich nur ein beispiel nennen die
malische regierung hat jetzt
friedensverhandlungen angenommen und
angefangen mit rebellengruppen wo die
franzosen zur sprache geweigert haben
auch nur mit ihnen zu sprechen ich will
sagen das kann nur dazu führen diese
gespräche dass wir frieden finden mit
denen die dort an der macht sind und nur
das führt dazu dass die lage wieder
stabilisiert wird alles andere ist doch
gescheitert und deshalb dort muss
verhandelt werden man muss anerkennen
dass dort die an der macht sind die
verhandlungen führen und das ist was wir
akzeptieren und anerkennen müssen und zu
allerletzt das beispiel warum man dort
ist gilt ja dann eigentlich für so viele
länder auf dieser welt da frage ich mich
wir müssten ja dann mit der bund sei
überall aktiv sein bleiben am besten
funktionieren aber mit molly und der
seine insgesamt waren sie direkt
erwehren ich hätte sonst auch noch ein
punkt aber
ich nehme den letzten punkt auf wir sind
nicht in jedem teil der welt weil es
nicht für jeden teil der welt einen
kleinen verein mandat gibt im rahmen der
vereinten nationen un ist wir sind dort
auf einladung expliziten auf wunsch in
zwei verschiedenen mandaten unterwegs es
ist ja nicht so dass gebunden dass die
bundeswehr und die präsenz dort nicht
willkommen wäre im gegensatz zum
gegenteil wir genießen dort einen
exzellenten ruf und es stimmt das nicht
alleine durch militärische mittel
frieden geschaffen werden kann ich hänge
einer solchen ideologie bei weitem nicht
an allerdings ist es so dass man eben
mit militärischen mitteln manchmal eine
gewisse atempause schaffen kann und auch
muss damit eben dann
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch
gewährleistet werden kann ich glaube da
ist einfach ein grundsätzlicher dissens
zwischen uns beiden und man muss dazu
gleichzeitig zahlen das ist ja kein
kampf einsatz sondern es ist ein
stabilisierungseinsatz die dazu dienen
soll das aufklärung geschaffen vollzogen
wird und dass wir auch möglichkeiten zur
verfügung stellen dass die bundeswehr
dort absichert und eben nicht kämpft
weekend und auch keine anti terror
operation dort leistet ich finde das ist
ein wirklich guter auftrag den die
bundeswehr dort leistung und ich weiß
wie gefährlich ist und weil ich die dann
auch an dieser stelle nochmal
ausdrücklich danken für den dienst den
sie dort leisten ich gebe ihnen noch
einen noch zwei punkte mit auf den weg
bevor sie antworten weil wir wissen ja
auch die lage in der sonne ist
gefährlich weil unter anderem
islamistische terrorgruppen unterwegs
sind weil keiner sich wieder ausbreitung
von denen man eine ganze weile aber
zumindest regel andere welt eher weniger
gehört hat sind russische soldat truppen
unterwegs die teilweise kooperieren wo
man auch nicht weiß auf welche blumen
weist schon auf welche seite sie sich
ungefähr schlagen das heißt also wie sie
ein kompletter zurück zurückzog
der un-truppen wir jetzt da sind würden
doch mutmaßlich zumindest im film zum
kompletten kollaps in der region für das
alles überhaupt nicht weil es einfach
feststellen erstens mal wurde ja damals
von den regierungen eingeladen sowie ja
gerade gegründet wurde diese regierung
sind nicht da die jetzigen regierung
holen sich russland zu hilfe und
begründen das genauso mit den argumenten
wie sie die westliche hilfe zuvor geholt
haben deshalb glaube ich erst mal nicht
dass ein kollaps gilt ist befürchte er
dass wir uns dort in einen wettbewerb
gegeben werden beziehungsweise die
bundesregierung muss man mit russland
einerseits konkurriert im übrigen ist
russland mittlerweile auch in burkina
faso in der zentralafrikanischen
republik das spricht ja für
einflusszonen und den kampf darum aber
auch china ist mittlerweile dort aktiv
mit enorm vielen finanzmitteln und ich
sage ihnen ganz offen dass wir diese
bundesregierung diesem wettbewerb gar
nicht gewinnen können weil so viel geld
wie china investiert und so viele
menschen leben die russland bereit ist
auch dort zu opfern an den eigenen
kräften das würde die bundesregierung
richtigerweise nicht tun und deshalb
können wir diesen wettbewerb der dort
stattfindet gar nicht gewinnen frag ich
mal fix musikdirektor nachfrage habe
weiß nicht fahrlässig da jetzt raus zu
gehen und dann russischen söldnertruppen
beispielsweise das feld zu überlassen
wir sehen doch im moment die wie
instabil die lage ist die sind doch
gekommen weil die dort aktiven die
un-mission aber auch heute als nicht
ausreichend und akzeptabel gefunden
haben das haben sie auch sehr deutlich
gesagt und sie unterstellen sogar im
moment frankreich autos und ein zweiter
versuch gegeben hätte von seiten der
franzosen noch einmal die logik lehne
ich ab wenn wir so anfangen zu sagen wir
kämpfen dort weil wir die russen dort
nicht raum überlassen wollen wo wir
sollte das denn enden mit verlaub und
die islamistischen terroristen war nicht
vergessen von geladen
ich würde einfach gerne
und der argumente ist von einem punkt
dagegen zu setzen dort kämpft niemand
also die veränderungen sind nicht da um
dinge zu kämpfen zu erkämpfen oder
irgendwas wir sind da um aufzuklären um
um die zivilbevölkerung zu schützen um
die verteilzentren zu schützen und die
um die ernährungssituation einigermaßen
abzusichern und ich bleibe bei dem wir
das ist ein intensiv patient wenn wir
dort jetzt den stecker mit - maxim dann
wird er intensiv patienten versterben
wir wissen nicht ob er mit - ma
überleben wird aber wir können mit
sicherheit sagen dass er ohne - sterben
wird und ich glaube dass es in punkt
wenn wir dann uns auch überlegen die
salz ohne schein zwar weit weg zu sein
aber letztendlich es ist sind es zwei
länder es ist ein algerien und dann
frankreich will bis die menschen auch
internationaler terrorismus dann bei uns
sein könnte und ich finde dass es uns
alle etwas angeht was in der welt
passiert und wir haben ein klares mandat
durch die vereinten nationen und auch
ihr meine eine willkommen heißen durch
das malerische regime das sich wie sie
sicherlich auch nicht als legitim an
ziehe aber nichtsdestotrotz es ist nicht
dass die internationale gemeinschaft aus
dem land geworfen werden soll insgesamt
dagegen den willen der regierung oder
der bevölkerung wäre sondern das
gegenteil ist der fall schließlich
können gleich antworten damit schließt
eben auch noch mal eine frage an welche
lehren eigentlich muss man oder kann man
ziehen aus dem gescheiterten einsatz in
afghanistan wenn man das jetzt vergleich
mit der lage in mali muss man da nicht
aussagen aus meiner sicht dass der
einsatz in afghanistan überhaupt nicht
gescheitert wir sehen jetzt ja dass erst
der abzug der internationalen präsenz
dazu geführt hat dass die taliban wieder
die schrecken der stadt berichten diese
richten gibt die bilder die berichte aus
afghanistan erschüttert mich zutiefst
und wenn man dann anguckt was dort eben
mit dem vernetzten ansatz mit zum teil
mit kapuze die building mit auch mit dem
aufbau von sicherheitsstrukturen
geschaffen wurde heißt es dass für 20
jahre ein relatives maß an sicherheit
gewährt wurde für die zivilbevölkerung
und für mich ist der einsatz bei km
keinster weise gescheitert aber in
menschen bilden also nutzt nun bild er
hat auch nicht funktioniert ziemlich
funktionieren hat nicht funktioniert
heißt trotzdem nicht dass man alles in
bausch und bogen klein reden da fallen
man muss einfach konzertieren dass erst
der abzug dazu geführt hat dass das land
komplett kollabiert ist jetzt sind sie
endlich wieder also erst einmal zudem zu
dem argument dass wir dort helfen und
ähnliches faktor ist das doch daran an
dem was dort stattfindet wir haben seit
einsatz von - also der un-mission eine
vervierfachung der terroranschläge
islamistischer gruppierungen die anzahl
dschihadistischer gruppierung hat sich
versechsfacht in der zeit und sie nutzen
definitiv auch das un mandat um sich
immer wieder zu stärken und diesem druck
auf zu erhöhen und afghanistan mit
verlaub promille da muss schon sagen das
hier ist natürlich anders das wissen sie
auch der ist brachial gescheitert dieser
einsatz deshalb hat man sich im übrigen
zurückgezogen und im übrigen hat man zu
stadt auch auf andere verlassen nämlich
die usa sowie in der sahelzone auf
frankreich und das ist fatal
jetzt können wir noch eine halbe stunde
weitermachen können wir aber gar nicht
weil ich plenum gleich losgeht und sie
müssen rein die ersten
tagesordnungspunkte befassen sie sich
mit mahlers spannend eigentlich wollte
ich noch über sondervermögen reden und
die zukünftige ausrichtung der
bundeswehr auch im hinblick auf solche
auslandseinsätze aber nicht geschafft
kommen wir bald man nach vielen dank
dass ich heute morgen danke sagen wir
danke frau müller dankte ihm wäre an der
lamy sie dürfen hier weil sich auch weil
sie ja auch reingehen müssen wir schauen
mal hier noch indirekt ins plenum rein